a year unlike any
in its 73 year history the birth of the
nhs
celebrated with a thanksgiving service
where the debt of gratitude
is incalculable as well as thanksgiving
this is a service of commemoration
but how to mark this terrible pandemic
for some
it is still too soon too raw
too personal for others
a need to make sense of our shared
experiences
countless lives have been lost but
thousands have been saved
due to visiting restrictions the staff
became ruby's surrogate family
catherine dawson was 32 weeks pregnant
when she was admitted to an icu
before she was ventilated she was
comforted by her consultant
who told her he wasn't prepared to let
her die
after four weeks i was introduced to
ruby and never seen her before apart
from on a video link
and it was amazing you know holding a
tiny bundle
that i'd not seen before it was very
surreal i wouldn't be here if the nhs
weren't here
um you know even neonatal my daughter
was born and she was well
but without the early care she might not
have made it
away from saint paul's a young composer
expressed his gratitude
for the nhs through music apollo
promedaza was just
six when he composed the piece last year
he was performed
by medical staff from bart's health
trust
the queen two has paid tribute by
awarding the nhs the george cross
only the third time the medal for the
greatest acts of heroism
has been awarded collectively and on the
lawns of the palace prince william
hosted the nhs big tea party
but the duke could not be joined by his
wife kate who is self-isolating
after coming into contact with a
positive covid case
a reminder that as we pay tribute to the
dedication of our health workers
their emergency is not open
[Music]
iva bennett sky news at saint paul's
cathedral